teaching really matters
and finding the right teachers really
matters
[Music]
in a classroom
the teacher not only provides knowledge
and skills
but also is a living example of the
power that education has
your knowledge of everything and your
ability to teach that to a student are
two distinct aspects of education you
have to have excellent content knowledge
but you also have to have the skills
required to give that knowledge and to
help students access that content in
ways that are appropriate for their
grade level
if you think that you're going to be the
sage on the stage you're going to be
mistaken because what actually happens
is that you're learning and developing
your craft and getting better at what
you do and that requires a certain
humility and it requires a pursuit of
constant knowledge if you are in a sense
the intellectual peer
of the other students in the classroom
that's a great moment
because as a teacher you stop and in a
moment of vulnerability you say i am
stumped by the greatness of this thing
help me
they jump in and those moments they're
just the best and it is rewarding
because
the light bulb goes off in teachers just
like it does in students
we provide our teachers with a lot of
training and a lot of mentorship we
provide our teachers with one week of
training on the hillsdale k-12
curriculum that we offer and then after
that week we bring our teachers to our
campuses and we provide them with a
thorough introduction to every aspect
that they need to know in order to have
a successful school year i can get on a
zoom call and speak with the people who
are helping with the literature the
literacy in hillsdale and i can be
connected to different schools in the
united states and we're all talking
about what's going on in our
schools that's why it's really
encouraging to me that we have the
relationship with hillsdale and the
national relationship with all the other
schools
that's a lot of people
a lot of very smart people in very
different places in circumstances
thinking about the same thing so not
only do i feel
challenged as a teacher to be my very
best
but i also feel like i have the best
behind me
it took a minute for me to kind of
settle in and realize for the first time
in my teaching career
i am actually being treated like a
professional
this curriculum that we provide gives
schools vertical alignment the ability
to make sure that
there's a plan for the students they're
going somewhere and the curriculum is
helping them get there everything flows
and connects so well because of the way
the curriculum is built not only are the
subjects vertically aligned which means
that they slowly progress from one year
to the next but also horizontally
aligned so that in your grade level that
you're teaching you can see the
connection between a history unit a
literature unit and even a math unit
that's what makes it so special is that
while we're learning in history about
world war one we're simultaneously
reading animal farm in literature which
is based
exactly on the events that were
happening in russia at that time i know
that the wonder and of education which
is the beauty of childhood
is in my classroom because of the
curriculum that i've been given the
opportunity
to
expose my students to
[Music]
i was looking for a place
that
clearly said we are interested in
students learning
and becoming virtuous people
and it doesn't get much more simple than
that and the staff here is united in
that effort it's what i always wanted i
just didn't know it existed
i got my teaching degree at the age of
63
and i would encourage anybody to get the
opportunity to work at a school that
teach classical education it is never
too late
if you're a teacher who values the
rich education of students not only for
the sake of gaining knowledge but also
for the sake of becoming good formed
citizens
come to our schools because what we
offer students is a constant variety of
rich exposure to the great ideas
[Music]
you